well the cia doubling down on its woke
recruitment ads
the second video now making waves
features a member of the lgbtq community
who describes himself as an agency
librarian and the cia claiming inclusion
is a core value
imagine my surprise when i was taking my
oath at cia
and i noticed a rainbow on then director
brennan's lanyard which i later learned
was designed by angle
one of the many employee resource groups
here at the agency i remember being
stunned
since then however i've learned that far
beyond the resource groups
inclusion is a core value here officers
from the top down work hard to ensure
that every single person
whatever their gender gender identity
race
disability or sexual orientation can
bring their entire self to work
every day
part of a human series on the cia
recruitment
i guess i hope they get it done before
ted lasso because that starts in june
joining us now the nationally syndicated
radio host herself dana lash
and buck sexton host of the buck sexton
show and a former cia analyst
dana let's start with you i thought
after the first one they'd correct
course but they doubled down
why i have no idea brian
and nobody cares nobody cares about
identity politics look is being gay
going to make you
spy on people less i mean if especially
if they're going to talk about john
brennan
is being gay going to make you lie to
congress and break into staffers emails
and spy on people less
is being gay meaning that mean that
you're going to kill people less i mean
seriously what
what does this even matter just do your
job
nobody cares do your job that's all that
matters brian i can't believe that this
is even a topic of conversation because
this is how crazy the world has gotten
right nobody's anti-inclusion but when
it comes to the cia
you want jason bourne i thought buck
sexton am i correct
yeah well that's certainly what people
would like to believe goes on to the cia
i can tell you
that there is actually a lot of paper
pushing and
sitting in long boring meetings and
drinking lattes but there's also
very important work that goes to the
national security of this country
protecting people
and defeating the enemy and there should
be a real sense
of of the need to be willing to take it
to the other side
and do what is necessary whatever the
cost may be whatever that
you know obviously within the scope of
the law and this notion that somehow
making the focus of the agency's
recruitment efforts
increasingly on what you would call
diversity and inclusion
and multiculturalism a lot of this
left-wing jargon
is disheartening for people because we
just want the best the same way we're
talking about a brain surgeon the same
way you're talking about
you know somebody who's who's at the top
of the national security hierarchy
we want the people that get the job done
and yes we don't care what their
background is
we don't care what their preferences may
be or what their ethnic origin may be we
just
want the best americans working in this
fight and these videos undermine that
i've had a lot of former people from the
agency
reach out to me and just say it's it's
embarrassing for us
we've got to worry about china not worry
about the numbers of diversity inclusion
hey guys i want to get to this next
topic too
because it's about how we live our lives
the cia is supposed to be watching our
back
and uh we would hope science is going to
get our mass off and us back to work and
back to our lives
but certain some reason the science is
not caught up with practicality
and even jake tapper on cnn is
questioning why
the president is wearing a mask
everywhere even though he's vaccinated
listen the cdc has given guidance that
when you're with family and friends that
are vaccinated in small groups
you don't need a mask so why does
president biden in a room full of
vaccinated journalists
with everybody in that room vaccinated
why does he need to wear a man president
is going to continue to follow the cdc
guidance
but dana it's not the guidance of the
cdc
he's giving the wrong message
yeah and you wonder why people are
confused and then they become
suspicious over this because of the
messaging from the administration
there's so many times that the
administration
has contradicted the cdc whether it's
you know how
you know whether it's for a vaccination
of pregnant women or
six feet versus three feet or you know
etc etc the messaging has been really
really murky
and i mean when you have that when you
have him going out he's vaccinated he's
wearing a mask outside there's not a
soul around
and what what message are you sending to
people good reasonable people brian are
not trying to be conspiracy theorists
they just want clear answers from the
government and imagine if there was this
entity
that existed of people who could report
on what was happening with the
government and actually tell americans
that
the press maybe if we had something like
that that could do it without being
propagandists
uh a buck you know people that don't
want to get vaccinated and you want them
get i have a reason to do it
you watch the president united states
that's a reason not to do it because
nothing changes in your life
well this is the critical point i agree
with everything dana's saying about
the contradictory messaging and it's
absurd and six feet three feet
60 feet who knows what's going on day to
day here they change it all the time
it's arbitrary but beyond that the
messaging campaign that they've been
failing in so far is failing because
people don't feel like they get to go
back to normal because of people like
biden
yeah it's unbelievable because now they
want everyone going back to college with
vaccinations you don't get back on
campus
well part of the deal is then let me go
back to normal if i go back
no masks no distance game on
that's what's got to be it they don't
see the good side in anything
they just want to restrict or use the
word privilege it's got to stop dana and
buck thanks so much
thanks brian privilege to get your life
back hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now